♪ You gotta go and get
angry at all of my honesty ♪
♪ You know I try, but I don't
do too well with apologies ♪
♪ I hope I don't run out of time ♪
♪ Could someone call a referee ♪
♪ 'Cause I just need one
more shot at forgiveness ♪
♪ I know you know that
I made those mistakes ♪
♪ Maybe once or twice ♪
♪ And by once or twice ♪
♪ I mean maybe a couple of hundred times ♪
♪ So let me, oh, let
me redeem, oh, redeem ♪
♪ Oh, myself tonight ♪
♪ 'Cause I just need one
more shot at second chances ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Is it too late now to say sorry ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm missing more
than just of your body ♪
♪ Oh, is it too late now to say sorry ♪
♪ Yeah, I know that I let you down ♪
♪ Is it too late to say sorry now ♪
♪ I'm sorry, yeah ♪
♪ I'm just trying to get you back on me ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm missing more
than just of your body ♪
♪ Oh, whoa ♪
♪ Is it too late now to say sorry ♪
♪ Yeah, I know that I let you down ♪
♪ Sorry, yeah ♪
♪ Is it too late now to say sorry ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)